One very hot day, Lion went to the sea.
Just as Lion walked into the sea, Sea Dragon swam up.
"This is my sea," Sea Dragon said.
"You must stay out of it. Now show me your strength," Sea Dragon said to Lion.
Some monkeys heard Lion talking to Sea Dragon.
"We must help Lion," one of them said.
Golden Rabbit turned to his friend, the Black Mynah Bird.
"Fly everywhere and tell all the animals to come here as soon as they can."
Soon, animals of every kind came to the meeting.
Golden Rabbit said, "Lion is in danger."
"But we know that only the dragon-eating Galon Bird can beat Sea Dragon."
"Therefore, we must find an animal who can pretend to be the dragon-eating Galon Bird."
A very big bird walked forward.
"I can help, my name is Quilt Bird."
Golden Rabbit said, "You are very big, but Sea Dragon will not be afraid of you."
"But I have a plan."
The next day, Lion and all the animals hid behind some trees near the sea.
Golden Rabbit walked toward the sea.
Sea Dragon swam up. "So a rabbit is going to fight me instead of Lion."
Black Mynah Bird made a noise.
Then, all the animals made as much noise as they could.
"That noise is the dragon-eating Galon Bird," Golden Rabbit said, "she's very hungry."
Sea Dragon was swimming away as fast as he could.